صور جويه تظهر وسوليدار مدمره واستعداد
البولندي لتزويد اوكرانيا بدبابات
اليوبارد في اطار التحالف الدولي
العفو الدوليه تطالب ايران بوقف جميع
الاعدامات المتعلقه بالاحتجاجات فورا
وتصفها بالتعسفيه
التحقيقات الاوليه تكشف خللا باحد ملفات
نظام الاشعارات الجويه واداره الطيران
الامريكيه تستبعده هجوما سيبرانيا
[موسيقى]
طب شو مطابقه اوقاتكم اهلا بكم الى هذه
النشره الاخباريه من العربيه
افادت مصادر ميدانيه ان الجيش الاوكرانيه
يقوم بارسال المزيد من الجنود الى جبهه
سوليدار للقضاء على مقاتل فاجنر مضيفا
اشتباكات عنيفه جدا تدور بين الجانبين هذا
واعلنت وزاره الدفاع الاوكرانيه بان الجيش
الروسيه تكبد خسائر فادحه في العتاد
والارواح على ذلك المحور
[موسيقى]
فاليري كريسماس رئيس هيئه الاركان العمل
الروسيه يصبح القائد الجديد للعمليه
العسكريه باوكرانيا ولد في مدينه قازان
عام
1955 تخرج من مدرسه خزان العليا للدبابات
درس في الاكاديميه العسكريه للقوات
المدرعه وتخرج منها عام
والاكاديميه العسكريه للهيئه الاركان
العامه للقوات المسلحه الروسيه عام 19970
عينا بمناصب عسكريه عده ابرزها رئيس اركان
منطقه شمال القوقاز العسكريه
ورئيس اركان منطقه الشرق الاقصى العسكريه
نائب رئيس هيئه الاركان العامه عام 2010
رئيس هيئه الاركان العامه الروسيه منذ عام
2012 حتى الحادي عشر من يناير عام 2023
اهلا يا رئيس البولنديه اندريه دوده خلال
زياره الى اوكرانيا ان بلاده مستعده
لتزويد كيف باربعه عشره دبابه ثقيله
متطوره من نوع اليوبارد 2 على ان يحصل ذلك
في اطار تحالف الدولي يجرى العمل حاليا
على بنائه واشار الرئيس البولندي الى انه
يعتمد على دول اخرى للمساهمه في عمليات
تسليم هذه الدبابات بدوره اعلن الرئيس
الليتواني جيت اناس
ان بلاده سترسل ايضا الى اوكرانيا انظمه
مضاده للطائرات من نوع زنات مع دخيلتها
الرئيس الاوكراني
نظيره البولنديه قائلا ان بلاده تتوقع
قرار مشتركا تشاركه فيه دول اضافيه اخرى
مستعده لارسال دبابات ليوبالت
قبل اقل من عام بدات روسيا عمليتها
العسكريه بدخول اقليم جمباز من الشرق فما
هي ابرز محطات العمليه الروسيه شرقي
اوكرانيا القوات الروسيه وصلت التقدم في
مارس واقتربت من السيطره على اول مدينه
اوكرانيه كبيره شمال شرقي البلاد وهي كما
نشاهد هنا حركات انتصار وصف بالاستراتيجيه
تحقق في شهر مايو بالسيطره على ماريوبل
المطله على بحر از اوف بعد صمود نحو جندي
اوكرانيه داخل مصنع ازاكستان للصلب لحوالي
الشهر بعد السيطره الروسيه على ماريو بيل
ومدن عده
بقيت على الجانب الاخر في الشرق مدينه
حينها في الثامن والعشرين من مايو تمكنت
القوات المواليه لروسيا من السيطره على
مدينه ليمان مركز مهم السكك الحديديه في
منطقه دونياس كما هو معروف في يونيو
الماضي اعلن حاكم لو جانسك سيطرت القوات
الروسيه على مدينه سيبردونيس الاستراتيجيه
في الثالث من يوليو وبعد احكام السيطره
على دنيا
اعلنت القوات الروسيه السيطره على منطقه
لوجاست فيما تبقى امامها منطقه دونياس
لاحكام قبضتها على اقليم دومباز باكمله
انا ذاك كما نذكر شهر سبتمبر شهد مشاهدينا
تقدما اوكرانيا شرقي مع السعاده بلدات
رئيسيه بينها ايثيون في ديسمبر وبدايه
العام الجديد تتركز الجهود الروسيه على
مدينتي سيفرياس وباخمط المجاورهتين
وسوليدار المجاوره هي الطريقه الاقرب
لتحقيق هذه الاهداف
طلبه منظمه العفو الدوليه النظام الايراني
بوقف جميع عمليات الاعدام المتعلقه
بالاحتجاجات التي تشهدها البلاد فورا
وادانه المنظمه في بيان ما وصفته بالاعدام
التعسفي لكل من محمد مهدي كرامه وسيد محمد
حسيني محضره من ان هناك اخرين يواجهون نفس
المصيده وقالت ديانا الطحاوي نائبه مدير
المكتب الاقليمي للشرق الاوسط وشمالي
افريقيا
بالمنظمه ان استمرار النظام طهران في موجه
القتل وسعيه لانهاء الاحتجاجات من خلال
اشاعه الخوف بين الناس هو امر نقيت
اعلنت رئيسه بلديه بلده نوفل لو شاتو قرب
باريس انه سيتم ان نزع صوره للخميلي وضعت
في ارض خاصه حيث اقام الخميني اواخر
السبعينيات خلال فتره المنفى ياتي هذا
القرار عقب طلب من رابطه القانون الدولي
للنساء التي تمثل 40 منظمه غير حكوميه
وجمعيه فم ازادي
قالتها الخارجيه الفرنسيه ان النظام
الايراني مسؤول عن امن مصالحها ومواطنيها
في ايران كما نصحت وزاره الخارجيه
بتحذيرا
للفرنسيين بعدم الذهاب الى ايران نظرا
لارتفاع مخاطر الاحتجاز التعسفي من قبل
السلطات طهران على حد وصف المسؤول
الفرنسيه
يثير اعدام محتاجين شقا في ايران وتعليق
جتا فيهم على رفعات خوفا شديدا بدرجه اثرت
على ما يبدو على الاحتجاجات الشعبيه غير
ان محللنا وخبراء رجحوا ان ذلك لن يدوم بل
يرونا ان لجوء الدوله الى العنف الدامي
سيدفع المعارضه الى العمل السري وفقا
رويترز
بتعليق المشانق في جمهوريه الخوف يسع نظام
الايراني
تكتيكاته القمعيه التي لجا اليها لاخضع
احتجاجات سابقا
التوقعاته تشير الى ان الظلمه والعنف
الدموي سيقابل بالعنف المضاد وستجبر
لمعارضه على العمل السري فاحكام الاعدام
واساليب الترهيب تحييما شهدته المناطق
العربيه والكرديه ومناطق البلوش في ايران
من مقاومه المسلحه السريه وعلانيه تم
خوضها على فترات مع اجهزه النظام في
ثمانينات القرن الماضي الى الالفيات
الثانيه
الناس اما في السجن او اتجه للعمل السري
لانهم مصممون على ايجاد طريقه لمواصلات
النظام
رئيسي الذي يرفض بغطاء من المرشد اي حوار
مع المحتاجين الذين وصفهم بالعملاء رئيس
الذي احيا تصريحه في اذهان الايرانيين
دوره في لجنه الموت التي علقت المشانق
لالاف المعتقلنا الايرانيين في الثمانينات
تجمع المعارضه ذكر وبحسب موقع تصوير 1500
انه وفي رساله تحذير للنظام ردد المحتجون
شعار ساقتل من يقتل اخي
كما تشير تقارير داخل يا مسربه الى انه
ربما تم اعتقال ما يصل الى 115 عنصرا
عسكريا لدعمهم الاحتجاجات مع اشاره تقارير
محليه الى رفض المتظاهرين سياسه النظام
التي يصفونها بغير المتوازنه لاعطائها
الافضليه للنفوذ الخارجيه على حساب ماشره
مركز الاحصاء الايراني لان الايرانيين
المعرضين لخطر الفقر المتوقع قد ارتفعت
الى 50%
حنان المصري العربيه
جددت اوكرانيا على لسان سفيرها في
بريطانيا تحميلا النظام الايراني مسؤوليه
اسقاط الطائره الاوكرانيه ورفضها السفير
الاوكرانيا ان تكتفي طهران بالقاء اللوم
على جندي جندي ضغط على زر نتج عنه اسقاط
طائره كما شدد على ضروره ان يحدد النظام
الايراني هويته جميع القاده الذين شاركوا
في قتل العدد الكبير الركاب الطائره
نشرتنا مستمره وفيها بعض الفاصل
بتوجيههم الخادم الحرمين الشريفين لاجراء
عمليه فصل الصيام العراقيه عمر وعلي اليوم
حياكم الله يخضع التوام السيامي العراقيه
عمر وعلي لعمليه فصلهما في مستشفى الملك
عبد الله التخصصيه للاطفال في العاصمه
السعوديه الرياض وكان التوام العراقيه قد
قدم الى السعوديه في سبتمبر الماضي بعد
توجيهات خادم الحرمين الشريفين الملك
سلمان بدراسه حال التوام والنظر في
امكانيه اجراء عمليه فصليهما
اغاني العديد من المعلمات المتطوعات في
تعز من ضربات القناصيه الميليشيات
المتمركزين الشرقيه مدينه تعز وتخوض عشرات
المعلمات المتطوعات مغامرات يوميه في
منطقه صاله شرق المدينه
للوصول الى المدرسه من اجل تلقين الطلبه
دروسهم قال نصوء المليشيات غيبوا عشرات
المعلمين والطلاب عن اسرهم جراء استهدافهم
في الطرقات والمدارس
لاجل هؤلاء تغامر بحياتها كل صباح للوصول
الى الصف تقطع جميله وبخوف مسافات لا
يحجبها شيء عن قناص المليشيات هي واحده
اذن من عشرات المتطوعات التي خذنا مغامرات
يوميه مع اسلحه الحوثيين من اجل تعليم
الطلبه في المدارس الواقعه بالقرب من خطوط
تماسي الحرب شرقي تعز احنا ساكنين في
منطقه الارجان في منطقه خط نار
وخد تماس احيانا عندما تحدث هناك مواجهات
تحدث صعوبه فنضطر ان نمشي بين الممرات
الامنه حتى نصل الى المدرسه
بناء الخيريه التي طبعا السنه الاولى
جابوا لنا مدته ثلاثه شهور اما السنه هذه
يعني مجرد في تنسيق ومدري عاد يعني الى
الان في تنسيق بس اما من بدايه الحرب الى
الان يعني ما فيش اي حافز بمبال رمزيه لا
تصل الى 40 دولارا في الشهر يقدمنا على
تلقين مئات التلاميذ دروسهم التعليميه في
المدرسه هذه التي عزف عنها المعلمون نتيجه
الحرب فاقطع الرواتب وسقوط عشرات المعلمين
والطلب بين قتيل وجريح بالقنص والقصف
الحوثي في منطقه صاله شرقا اثر كثيرا على
العمليه التعليميه فيها
ثبت الشلال والجعشاء لن نستطيع ان نبقى في
المدرسه بسببها عمليه القنص التي تتملي
الطلاب المدرسين وراحوا الطلاب كثير قنصه
ومدرسين استشهد المدرسين لنا من ضمن
نتيجه همم وجود المنطقه في خط التماس
التسرب كثير من الطلاب وخسرنا الفتيات
للمدرسه بخوف لما نجينا دروس
بعدك اليوم انا صوخي هناك داخل الزغط الان
احنا نطلعك بالخوف لما ندرس نكون
خائفين لما نجزي عندكم نلبسهم الى المدرسه
الثانيه ولما يوقعوا خمس مده كذا اخر
المدرسه لما يقولوا لي امورنا
متتاليه
مدرسه عمر بن عبد العزيز من هذا المنزل
مكان لتعليم الطلاب بعد ان وضعت المليشات
مدرستهم تحت نيرانها وضع ماساوي يجسد واقع
التعليم في المدارس القريبه من خطوط
المواجهه كل شيء في هذه المنطقه صار مهددا
بالخطر نتيجه الحرب الحوثيه فهذه المدرسه
التي تحوي اكثر من 600 طالب وطالبه
تقابلها قناصات حوثيه متمركزه على تمام
تترصد حياتهم كلهم
دروسهم التعليميه بخطر دائما
هايل سعيد العربيه من مديريه صاله شرقي
تعز
افادت اداره الطيران الفيدراليه الامريكيه
ان الفرقه المختصه توصل البحث لمعرفه
اسباب تعطل النظام الملاحه الجويه النوته
وان التحقيقات الاوليه اظهرت خللا في احد
ملفات النظام فيما استبعدت اداره الطيران
الفيدراليه الامريكيه ان يكون النظام تعرض
لهجوم سبراني
مع استئناف في عمليات الطيران بعد انقطاعا
لمده ساعه ونصف الساعه اكد وزير النقل
الامريكيه ان قرار الاداره بمنع اقلاع
جميع الرحلات كان القرار الصحيح وانه يجرى
العمل لفهم ما حدث للتاكد من عدم تكرار
المشكلاتهم هي الاول
ويه لهذا اليوم على سبيل المثال بين مكانه
المشكله قيد الحل تم وقف عمليات الاقلاع
لساعه ونصف على مستوى الولايات للتاكد من
عدم اقلاع اي طائره دون معلومات الامان
لازمه دائما ما ستكون اولوياتنا هي
السلامه في الوقت ذاته نحرص على فهم كل ما
يتعلق بهذه الحاله للتاكد من عدم تكرارها
افادت وسائل الاعلام ان امريكيه نقلا عن
مصادر مطلعه بان مساعدي الرئيس الامريكي
جو بايدن اكتشفوا مجموعه جديده من الوثائق
السريه في احد المكاتب التي عمل فيها بيضه
وقال مصدر للقناه الامريكيه انه بعد
اكتشاف المجموعه الاولى من الوثائق السريه
في نوفمبر الماضي بدا المساعدون بالبحث عن
موده سريه قد تكون موجوده في مكاتب اخرى
ولم يكشف المصدر عن اي تفاصيل بشان
الجديده من الوثائق
جرح سته اشخاص بينهما ضابط شرطه فرنسيه
اثرت تعرضهم للطعن بمحطه قطارات قطارات
الشمال المكتظه في العاصمه باريس فيما
تمكنت الشرطه الفرنسيه من تحديد الجانب
بطلقات الناريه نقل على اثرها الى
المستشفى وذكرت وسائل واعلامها فرنسيه
نقلا عن مصادر امنيه ان مرتكب الاعتداء
ليبي وصل الى فرنسا قبل ثلاث سنوات وانه
معروف بسوابقه جنائيه
من هذا المكان دخل المعتدي في الصباح
الباكر الى محطه جارجونال جرح شخصا عند
المدخل وخمسه اخرين في الداخل قبل ان تطلق
الشرطه ثلاث رصاصات على ايه اقعدته في
المستشفى بين الحياه والموت تقول وسائل
اعلام ومصادر امنيه ان المعتدي ليبيا في
العشرينيات من عمره كان وصل الى فرنسا قبل
ثلاث سنوات وكانت الشرطه اصدرت قرارا لم
ينفذ بترحيله الى بلده لم يكن معروفا من
قبل اجهزه الاستخبارات بالانتماء الى
جماعه ارهابيه بل كان معروفا من قبل
الشرطه بارتكاب سوابقه
امر القضاء الاسبانيه بوضع امراتين في
الحبس الاحتياطي بعدما اعدت الى بلدهما من
الشمال سوريا حيث كانت محتجزتين في مخيمات
اللعائلات مقاتلي داعش قرروا القضاء
الاسبانيه ياتي بعد الاشتباه بالامراتين
بارتكاب جنحه الانتماء الى منظمه ارهابيه
وفقه وثيقه قضائيه
برر نائب المتحدث باسم حركه طالبان بلال
كريمي قرار منع التعليم المراه في الجامعه
بانه من واجب الحركه تنظيم شؤون التعليم
والتنميه في افغانستان وفقا لاحكام الشرع
وفي مقابله خاصه مع العربيه قال ان نظام
طالبان منح المراه حقوقا لم تكن موجوده في
السابق
[موسيقى]
ان الامارات الاسلاميه
في مجالات اخرى
كما قلل نائب المتحدث باسم حركات طالبان
بلال كريمي من اهميه وجود تنظيم داعش في
افغانستان ووصفه بالظاهره التكفيريه غير
المرئيه وهكذا ان الاماره قضت على
98% من اوكار التنظيم مشيرا الى عدم وجود
حاضنه شعبيه له في افغانستان
تم القضاء على
98% من عناصر التنظيم وتم تدميره ولكن من
المؤسف ان بعض الدوائر تدعمه من خلال
الاعلام او تموله الاستغلاله ولكن في
الممارسه العمليه ما نراه في الواقع
الميداني لبلدنا هذه الظاهره لا تشكل
تحديا كبيرا وليست مصدرا قلق جاد للامن
الداخلي في بلادنا ولا يمكنه ان يشكل
تهديدا من افغانستان الى دول اخرى
[موسيقى]
مهما لكي نحتاج الى دول اخرى لمواجهته
داعش ليس تنظيما قويا وليسا مهما يتمكن من
تجنيد الاشخاص عندنا وليس له مناطق ثابته
في حيث نجد تخريبيا منفردا تطارده قوات
الدوله ومخابره الاماره الاسلاميه ويتم
تدمير اوكره
هذه المقابله لنائب المتحدثه باسم طالبن
بلال كريمه تعرض كامله اليوم في السادسه
عشره بتوقيت جرينتشها السابعه مساء بتوقيت
السعوديه على شاشه العربيه
[موسيقى]
قال وزير الدفاع الامريكيه لدى وسترنا
للولايات المتحده ستنشر وحده جديده من
قوات المارينز في جزيره اوكنا وجنوب
اليابان وذلك في محاوله للاستجابه بشكل
افضل للتهديدات الصينيه المتزايده وقال
اوستن في مؤتمر الصحفي مشترك بعد محادثات
مع وزير هي الدفاع والخارجيه اليابانيين
قال انه سيتم اعاده تنظيم القوات بحلول
عام 2025 الى فوج بحري ساحلي وذلك استجابه
لبيئه امنيه متزايده الصعوبه
في ان زياده نشاط القوات البحريه الصينيه
حول تايوان يعني ان غزوه الجزيره وشيك
وخلال المؤتمر الصحفي مشترك مع نظيره
الياباني
وزير الخارجيه خارجيه البلدين اضافها
هوستن ان واشنطن تعتقد ان بكين تسعى الى
انشائي وضع جديد في تايوان
صوره جويه تظهر سوليدار مدمره واستعداد
بولنديه لتزويد اوكرانيا بدبابه اليوبارد
في اطار تحالف دولي
العفو الدوليه طالب ايران بوقف جميع
الاعدامات المتعلقه بالاحتجاجات فورا
وتصفها بالتعسفيه
التحقيقات الاوليه تكشف خللا باحد ملفات
نظام الاشعارات الجويه واداره الطيران
الامريكيه تستبعد هجوما سيبرانيه
شكرا لكم
بعد دقائق
[موسيقى]